Good evening, everyone.
I trust you've had a fruitful day.
I do not say happy, though I hope it has been happy.
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Samha Sambuddhosa
Namo tassa bhagavato arahato sambha sambuddhasa.
Homage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble and fully self-awakened one.
So we were looking at this discourse, the Kittagiri discourse, where we came across these two characters.
Asaji and Punas, what was his name?
I've forgotten his name.
And they were miscreants.
They were untrained monks and all that sort of stuff.
And the Buddha has a go at them, if you remember.
And then he takes the opportunity to talk about seven types of individuals.
So these have been nicely categorized here by Shahrukh Rajel, Pressing Out Pure Honey, nice little book as accompaniment to the Majjhima Nikaya, the Middle and Saint.
So now, there are two interesting things here to note.
The first one is what's called a personal witness.
They abide by the formless attainments and, sorry, liberated both ways, excuse me, number one, liberated in both ways.
So these are the people
who through the jhana and through vipassana attain liberation.
And the liberated by wisdom, that's category number two, don't have to go through the jhana, they're liberated by wisdom.
So these are the arahants.
Now the rest all belong to the other three categories, the stream entrant, the first attainment, the once returner and the non-returner.
So the first one is that they, much the same as number one, they use the jhanas and vipassana, but all the defilements and not all the taints are not completely destroyed.
And then there's those who are without attaining those jhanas, but who review and examine with wisdom the teachings of the Buddha.
So they also make a path.
Then there's the ones liberated by faith without abiding in the formless attainments.
In other words, without the jhana, without the absorptions, with some tanks destroyed, but they have faith, is planted, rooted and established in the Buddha.
So this is the second thing.
The first one is that you don't need the jhana.
Remember that as lay people, it's very difficult to find the time and space to practice those absorptions.
You've got to give your heart to it.
but vipassana is very straightforward and can be done very easily as a lay person the other thing is the one by faith now confidence confidence a better word um you don't need the intellect so you don't need to be thinking uh about the buddha's teachings to some sort of fine degree
it's much more about about having confidence and what that confidence does is it it opens you up to to to view to investigate uh now people who don't have that confidence suffer from doubt they doubt the buddha was fully liberated the doubt that dharma really is going to go anywhere they doubt the teacher whom they're under and they cause doubt themselves all this doubt is overcome when one has confidence
So confidence is a root thing.
It belongs to the five spiritual faculties.
It begins with this confidence.
Then one puts the effort in, then one establishes the awareness, then the concentration rises quite naturally out of that interest and the wisdom factor is enlivened.
That's the intuitive intelligence which is brought in to see the three characteristics.
or suffering and not self so you can see that there are certain people who don't have to be you know always investigating reading about the dharma or anything it's good enough just to do the vipassana and then there are those that are planted right okay then there's the dharma followers
These are the ones who abide, who don't have the jhana again.
And the tents have not yet been destroyed, but they have a reflective acceptance of the teaching of the Buddha and those five faculties.
So that's the receptive acceptance.
That's more in the sense of an intellectual acceptance.
Again, there's no big need for that person.
to have a PhD in the Dharma.
And finally, there are the faith followers.
So abiding without, again, abiding in those jhanic states, the tanks have not yet been destroyed, but they have enough faith and love for the Buddha and the five spiritual faculties.
So what these categories of seven people tell us is, first of all, you don't need the jhana.
and B, you don't need to be highly intellectual at all.
one big story that supports this of course is the is the monk who joined who really didn't have much uh upstairs and um his brother actually said to him it was better for him to you know leave the order and do something useful and when the buddha heard this he went to see him and gave him a very simple exercise of taking a fresh piece of cloth rubbing it wiping the sweat off his face and things like that and constantly saying impermanence
impermanent everything's impermanent and would you believe it in no length of time he was fully liberated so uh it's good to know that you know we don't have to be big intellects to become liberated in fact it's often a big barrier so there's another story about that where um a very good teacher had all his students or many of his students were became fully liberated but he wasn't
So after a while, he thought to himself, well, you know, why is that?
And he sort of ate a humble pie and he went to see one of his students.
And his students, this particular student thought, no, this teacher's too conceited.
You know, whatever I say, he won't open up to it.
So I'll pass him on to somebody else.
So he said to him, actually, the person who really helped you is so-and-so.
And in this way, he was passed along the line of all his students until one student said to him,
Why don't you go with this young boy and he'll give you the trick, you see.
So this was a big humiliating thing to have to go to a young child for guidance in the spiritual life.
And the young child took him to a termite hill.
Now it seems that when termite hills are empty of termites, snakes live in them.
So he said to this teacher, if this termite hill has six holes and you want to get the snake out, how would you do it?
So he said, well, you block up five holes and the snake comes out.
And he said, that's what you must do in your meditation.
Block out the five senses and just observe the heart-mind.
And of course, in no length of time, the teacher became fully liberated.
So that's the bit of a teaching here about these seven types.
And in fact, you know, in my Zen practice, I remember them always saying if there's a hair's breadth of difference between, you know, sitting and your daily life, your daily life activity, you've lost the way.
So our effort is always to make what we're doing something upon which we are placing our attention.
It's wholesome.
We're putting our attention there and that's enough.
So then we have a very important statement when I finally get this thing going.
Just a minute.
Now, it's funny that this comes after these categories.
I do not say that awakening is achieved right away.
Rather,
Awakening is achieved by gradual training, gradual progress and gradual practice.
So that's important to understand is gradual.
Now, often when we come into the practice, it's very new to us.
And we practice what you might say with an open mind, an open heart, what Zen calls beginner's mind.
And usually we have, you know, insights and a lifting, and it really can have an immediate effect on our lives.
And then after a while, we keep practicing, practicing.
Nothing much happens.
You know, we think, well, you know, where's the progress?
Looking for progress.
Lots of meditators are seeking progress.
And it's good to remind ourselves that, you know, this is a very gradual path.
The Buddha says gradual, but I say very gradual.
And if you liken it to climbing a hill or climbing a mountain, remember you start off with all that energy and that, you know, you want to get to the top.
And then, you know, after, you know, a few minutes, even so, you can feel the heaviness in your legs.
and you begin to think well i need a rest and you sit down and when you sit down of course you get a bit of a view and that inspires you think oh well when i get to the top there'll be this fantastic view so you keep going and then you hit this plateau and the plateau keeps going on and nothing nothing happens but you can see that in the distance there's another rise and so the spiritual life goes up like that right up plateau up plateau
So even when you feel there's no progress, just by putting in the practice, by constantly bringing mindfulness to bear, we're moving very slowly, very gently.
We're on the path and it will take us there.
So that's good to remember.
Now, actually, he then says, how is this training achieved?
When someone in whom faith has arisen approaches a teacher,
They pay homage, lend an ear, hear the teachings, remember the teachings, reflect on their meaning and accept them after consideration.
Their enthusiasm springs up.
They make an effort, weigh up and persevere.
Persevering, they directly realize the ultimate truth and see it with penetrating wisdom.
Now he turns upon these two naughty monks.
There has not been that faith, that approaching, that paying homage.
that listening, that hearing of teaching, that remembering of the teaching, that reflecting on their meaning, their acceptance after consideration, that enthusiasm, that making an effort, that weighing up and that striving.
You've lost the way because you're practicing in the wrong way.
Just how far have these foolish people strayed from this teaching and training?
So he's giving them a real beating now.
And then he says,
And then he points out now, look, even if a teacher who values material things is an heir to material things, who lives caught up in material things, you wouldn't get into such haggling, right?
So even if a teacher's not very good at spiritual life or anywhere, really, you don't say, if we get this, we'll do that.
If we don't get this, we don't do that.
So remember, these monks were rebelling against the new rules about not eating in the evening,
etc.
So then he says, for a faithful disciple who is practicing to fathom the teacher's instruction, this is in line with the teaching.
The Buddha is my teacher, I am his disciple.
The Buddha knows, I do not know.
For a faithful disciple who is practicing to fathom the teacher's instructions, the teacher's instructions are nourishing and nutritious.
But a faithful disciple who is practicing to fathom the teacher's instruction, this is in line with the teaching.
And I'll listen to this.
Gladly let only skin, sinews and bones remain.
Let the flesh and blood waste away in my body.
I will not relax my energy until I have achieved what is possible by courageous strength, energy and vigour.
A faithful disciple who is practicing to fathom the teacher's instructions can expect one of two results.
Full liberation in this present life, or if there's something left, a non-returner, somebody who doesn't come back to be reborn here.
So there we are.
That's the instruction the Buddha is giving us, you see.
Let flesh and blood waste away in my body.
I will not relax my energy until I have achieved what is possible by courageous strength, energy, and vigor.
This is what the Buddha said, satisfied the bhikkhus were happy with what the Buddha had spoken.
So there's the challenge, you see.
There's the challenge.
Obviously, we want to make it easy.
We don't want to go to the extent of losing muscle.
So it's good to keep in mind that this practice has to be, you know, a real giving of self, a real devotion to it.
Now, of course, the Buddha here is giving us extreme examples, but I remember when Saibhupandita invited me to come with him to Burma.
Now, I had been to Burma before and had terrible time.
I got amoebic dysentery and then amoebic hepatitis, like, you know, it was bad news.
And I mentioned this to him that I was a little bit afraid of this, you see.
And the message he sent back was, you won't get anywhere unless you're prepared to die.
So this is the instruction by the Buddha.
we have to give everything in order to gain everything and with that in mind let us commit ourselves to our practice and be liberated from all this terrible suffering sooner rather than later so we can do a little practice